vous êtes très très amusant
j'ai eu dimanche soir je sais pas
pourquoi j'ai un truc me suis dit [ __ ]
faut que je fasse un sms à jean-pierre
et j'ai fait un sms à jean pierre en
disant je sais pas quel est son état de
santé mais s'il ne peut pas de lire
peut-être que nathalie vera et me
rappellera et nathalie m'a rappelé lundi
après midi elle est sortie de l'hôpital
georges pompidou il était depuis trois
semaines et elle m'a dit alors je
déteste faire ça que j'ai l'impression
d'entrer par effraction dans la vie
privée de cette famille est censé en y
avoir le droit et je pense qu'elle me
pardonnera de dire que ça faisait trois
semaines qu'elle leveilley jour et nuit
tout en ayant à préparer leur
déménagement parce qu'ils quittaient
leur maison pour s'installer anthony
vous avez trouvé une nouvelle propriété
et donc elle avait tout tout tout qui
tombait en même temps je les trouvais
mais absolument bouleversante de dignité
de tristesse de désespoir et je me suis
dit [ __ ] pourvu que j'ai pas à traiter
c'est ce que je vous ai écrit ce matin
pourvu que j'ai pas être traité ça sur
l'antenne de rtl mais j'avais
honnêtement un pressentiment alors ça
m'énerve d'entendre dire partout il est
mort de son cancer du sein on en parlait
dans un instant parce que oui on va
parler parce qu il va nous expliquer
vraiment isabelle ce qui s'est
réellement passé et les infos qu'on a
avec avec thierry qui ripe c'est une
perte un coup un jour pierre c'est ça va
c'est un monument ça c'est un monument à
télé 7 jours il a eu 7 4 7 d'or pour un
meilleur présentateur et en plus on
avait une image biaisée de jean-pierre
on le caricature et en
défenseur du terroir ce qu'il était
d'ailleurs parce qu'il aimait vraiment
ça mais il était capable vous avez passé
un magnéto tout à l'heure d'aller
ailleurs pour les pour le 11 septembre
donc c'était quelqu'un on avait une
image un peu biaisé ils pouvaient aussi
bien parler d'une fabrique de caramel à
guérande est allé à new york pour lui en
septembre parce qu'il s'était d'abord il
avait une faction très professionnel
peut faire son métier ça on ne le dit
pas assez parce qu'il est éraillée il
était snobé par une partie de
l'intelligentsia journalistique mais en
fait c'était surtout un grand pro sans
prompteur vous l'avez dit plusieurs fois
donc c'était quelqu'un qui était très
bon et moi le truc qui m'a le plus ému
c'est que il à médiatiser sa maladie non
pas pour qu'on verse des larmes sur lui
parce qu'il pensait vraiment et je pense
qu'il était
très fort là dessus ça pouvait aider des
gens et donc il à médiatiser sa maladie
a parlé de sa maladie parce que bah il
était comme tous les français qui ont
qui ont à traverser cette maladie moi
j'ai traversé l'année dernière pour
d'autres raisons et il ya beaucoup de
français qui disait que ça leur faisait
du bien aussi donc bien sûr j'en perds
pas de temps pour ça justement on va
parler et alors il a eu un premier
cancer en septembre 2018
la première fois c'était donc un cancer
de la prostate il avait dû laisser sa
place deux mois au jt de 13h de tf1 pour
se faire opérer il avait décidé d'en
parler lui-même sur ces réseaux sociaux
on regarde
salut à toutes et à tous je voulais vous
donner quelques nouvelles quinze jours
après mon opération
tout va pour le mieux comme vous pouvez
le constater certains journaux ont
inventé qui avait eu des complications
que j'étais dans une chambre médicalisée
avec une infirmière avec moi 24 heures
sur 24
c'est faux tout s'est bien passé vous
savez on est soixante dix mille tous les
ans à être opéré d'un cancer de la
prostate en france c'est pour ça que
j'en ai parlé il faut savoir se battre
et puis faire confiance aux médecins et
tout peut très bien se passer comme ça
s'est bien passé pour moi voilà je
voulais surtout vous remercier pour vos
innombrables messages de soutien après
cette opération ils me sont allés droit
au coeur et ça fait beaucoup beaucoup
énormément de bien salut à tous et à
bientôt le temps de me remettre
complètement salut
c'est vrai que son message il est
incroyable alors ça c'était son premier
cancer il avait pu finalement reprendre
sa place en novembre 2018 après son
opération regardez c'est un retour très
émouvant m
bonjour à toutes et à tous je suis
vraiment très très heureux de vous
retrouver aujourd'hui dans votre journal
j'en profite tout de suite pour vous
remercier de vos innombrables messages
de soutien je remercie vraiment de tout
coeur et puis merci aussi et bravo à
jacques legros et à toute l'équipe du
13h d'avoir fait un aussi beau journal
pendant toute cette période
donc après donc là c'était lors de son
son premier cancer second cancer en
nommant novembre 2021
il a vaincu ce premier concert de la
prostate au début il était en pleine
forme l'un un type et continue quand il
est revenu et il a dû une nouvelle fois
faire face à la maladie en novembre
dernier donc sa femme nathalie et qui
est venu nous annoncer qu'il était
atteint d'un nouveau conte ce cancer des
poumons de cette fois on regarde tous et
beaucoup donc j ce serait peut-être
temps que tu ailles faire de nouveau des
examens et puis donc il a fait un
premier examen et puis il disait il ya
quelque chose qui est pas très près
clair et puis comme il raconte il a fait
un pet scan & lamont le verdict est
tombé et moi je voulais je voulais faire
absolument l'opération parce que quand
vous faites l'opération vous retirez la
moitié du poumon et pouvait analyser il
pouvait savoir ce que c'est comme comme
cancer donc c'est très important de
savoir ce que c'est comme cancer et donc
ça s'est passé au mois de juillet on a
fait on est passé trois semaines à
l'hôpital il s'est fait opérer tout
s'est très bien passé et puis ben là au
mois de septembre ça attaque et l'autre
poumon donc par contre c'était un peu
plus chiant parce que
c'était un peu plus gros donc là bas il
est fait de la radiothérapie
et puis puis la moral d'acier et puis on
est au près de lui toute sa famille et
puis et puis se bat et puis comme on dit
jamais deux sans trois on a fait un
chacun un cancer et puis ma y en a un
autre qui vient qui le mot cancer savait
pas dire la mort automatiquement
alors quelques heures plus tard jean
pierre avait partagé la mauvaise
nouvelle sur les réseaux sociaux
toujours avec classe et optimisme ne
regarde
bonsoir juste un petit message pour
remercier tous ceux qui m'ont envoyé des
messages d'encouragement aujourd'hui je
suis très pris je n'ai pas pu
accompagner nathalie qui en a parlé chez
cyril hanouna pour pour confirmer cette
information
et si j'en parle d'abord parce qu'il
faut pas avoir peur du conseil en a déjà
eu un la prostate vous le savez pour
j'en ai parlé pour essayer d'améliorer
la prévention
même chose pour le poumon j'ai cru que
ça ne pouvait arriver qu'aux autres
pendant des années et des années on m'a
dit d'arrêter de fumer j'ai pas cru
j'aurais dû arrêter voilà je vous
tiendrai au courant tout va bien pour
l'instant on surveille tout est sous
contrôle salut et merci à vous c'est
vrai qu'on avait appris la nouvelle ici
c'était une véritable un véritable
vraiment très mauvaise nouvelle pour
nous parce que on était tous très
inquiet pour bourges en pire